hello everyone welcome to flexible
authorization with asp.net core
I'm Jason Taylor solution architect for
increment as you can see I'm a developer
Mentor speaker and trainer and most
recently awarded Microsoft MVP in
developer Technologies
I've been working with net since 1.0 in
2002 and before that I was doing VB
script and classic asp
today we're here to talk about flexible
authorization with asp.net core
and before we can dive into that very
interesting topic we have to cover a
little bit of background
so let's start with the basics
authentication is the process which
determines a user's identity
whereas authorization is the process
that determines which resources a user
can access
while authentication is independent of
authorization it's important to remember
that authorization requires an
authenticated user
so authorization determines access to
resources but what exactly is a resource
well it could include many things such
as access to a feature in a system files
on a file system or data in a database
authorization also includes defining and
enforcing access control rules as
policies which are then used by the
system to Grant or reject access
requests to specified resources
the focus of this talk will be
authorization with asp.net core
I'll demonstrate a basic approach using
role-based access control and you'll see
that for a sufficiently complex system
that that approach will slow developer
productivity and decrease overall
maintainability
then by extending the ISP net core
authorization framework I will
demonstrate a flexible approach to
overcome those limitations
now in this talk I'll provide some live
demonstrations using an app that was
built with Blazer webassembly and hosted
on asp.net core and I'll share a link to
the code and slides at the end of this
talk
so with asp.net core authorization it
supports simple authorization
capabilities such as allowing access to
an authenticated user
but it also includes some very
sophisticated checks such as role-based
claims-based policy-based view-based and
resource-based authorization
it's easy to create custom authorization
policies to verify very specific
requirements and it's also easy to
customize the authorization middleware
to suit your needs so we have a very
powerful framework Supply in both simple
and sophisticated capabilities with the
ability to extend it
let's start with some examples
in its simplest sense asp.net
authorization uses the authorized
attribute you can apply that to a
controller action or razor page
in this example the attributes being
applied to the account controller and
what this means is that only
authenticated users will be able to log
in or log out so clearly that's a
problem if we move the authorize
attribute down
Anonymous users will be able to access
the login action and authenticated users
will be able to access the logout action
we also have the allow Anonymous
attribute and so in this case the
accounts controller is locked down to
authenticated users except for the login
action which will allow Anonymous users
asp.net core supports role-based
authorization again using the authorized
attribute we can specify which roles are
required to access in this case the user
must be authenticated and be a member of
the administrator's role in order to
access the administrator controller
actions
in this case the user must be
authenticated and a member of either the
administrators or the accounts role
doesn't have to be both one will be fine
and in this case the user needs to be a
member of both so we specified two
authorized attributes and so the user
must be a member of Administrators and
accounts in order to gain access to the
accounts controller
asp.net core also supports policy-based
authorization
you can see here we've used the
authorize attribute and specified the
employee's only policy this means that
for a user to gain access to the
employee's controller they must be
authenticated and satisfy the
requirements of the employees only
policy
this is the definition of the policy
where we've specified the name as
employees only and the only requirement
it has is that the user has a single
claim the employee number Claim we're
not concerned with the value of the
claim or what their employee number just
that they have it
authorization and Blazer webassembly is
of course very similar being that it's
another asp.net core technology it
supports the same basic authorization
capabilities such as allowing access to
an authenticated user or allowing access
to Anonymous user
it includes the same sophisticated
authorization capabilities such as role
claims and policy based
and it also includes a number of helpful
authorization components such as the
authorized View and the authorized route
View and we'll take a look at some
examples
need to remember that with Blazer and
other front-end Technologies plays a web
assembly in this case the authorization
is only used for UI ux so it's to
provide a great user experience but this
these checks can easily be bypassed and
so the authorization that happens on the
server is very important
let's look at some examples we can apply
the authorized attribute to a routable
page in this case the home page will
only be accessible to authenticated
users
next up we're using the allow Anonymous
attribute if we like with blazer
webassembly we can lock the whole site
down to authorized users if that's the
case this allow Anonymous attribute will
allow unauthenticated users access to
the login page
we can support role-based authorization
in this case the counter page is only
accessible to members of the
administrators or accounts role
we can support policy-based
authorization the user's page is only
accessible to users who meet the
requirements of the employee's only
policy
and we have the authorized view
component which we can use to
selectively display content you can see
for the home link it'll be available to
authenticated users the counter link is
restricted you'll need to be a member of
either the administrators or the
accounts role and finally the user's
link is restricted you'll need to
satisfy the requirements of the
employees only policy
here we have an alternate use of the
authorized view component for not
authorized users this will show the
login page so in this case that means
anyone who's not authenticated
let's dive into our first demo in this
demo we're going to add a role to an
existing application now this will be
the basic approach to authorization
using role-based access control and the
scenario is that we have some Auditors
coming on board and we need to create an
Auditor's role which gives them the
necessary permissions within the system
so I've built a simple application as I
mentioned this is Blazer web assembly
hosted on asp.net core
and I'll go ahead and log in
log in as the administrator
and we can have a look at these features
so we have the home page the counter
page that's currently restricted to
administrators or the accounts team
because they like to count things
the fetch data one that's restricted to
the administrators or operations because
they need to check the weather
we have users most roles can view this
page but only administrators can edit
now if we go edit on the auditor you can
see we're able to specify which roles
this user will be a member of accounts
administrators or operations and of
course we'll need to add an Auditor's
role because none of the existing roles
will will meet the authorization
requirements we also have claims which
is just there for development purposes
at the moment we can see that there's an
interesting roles claim and it specifies
what role I have as an administrator
so if I'd like to create a new role I'll
need to do that in code I'm currently
doing it in my basic auth.server project
and I have a DB initializer so if I
expand that out
you can see here I've defined some roles
as constants I'm going to duplicate this
one
and re use multi-cursor and we'll uh
well that's not multico so hang on
there we go
we'll create our Auditors role you can
see that the users come with the default
password I watched a talk on hacking on
Wednesday and they said this password
was very popular at the moment so I
chose that one so everyone it's the
secure version of course right because
it's got the exclamation mark
all right
so now we need to add the role so I'll
duplicate this
use multi-cursor again I love that
feature
auditors
and that's about all we need to do so
we've created the Auditors role
we need it to kind of end up in the
database so I'll go ahead and restart
the app
give that a moment and then so the next
thing we need to do is we need to log in
as the administrator or go back as the
administrator assign the role to the
auditor then we can log in the auditor
and see see if they have access yet
let's see users
auditor
Auditors save
all right so the audit has been assigned
the Auditors role I can log out
log back in
change that to auditor
and of course it's the same password so
that users don't have to remember too
many passwords
all right now unfortunately the auditor
still doesn't have access to anything
right we've created the role but we're
using role-based access control so now
we have to go and put role-based Access
Control checks throughout our code we
want them to have access to the counter
fetch data and the list of users so
let's do that now we'll start on the
front end we've got a lot of work to do
so inside of client I'll go to pages and
I'll start with counter that's really
easy we have the authorize attribute
here so I'll go ahead and add Auditors
as one of the roles that will be able to
access the page
now we'd like to do fetch data that's
for the weather forecasts we'll include
Auditors there too
and we need to do users
and so this is for the list of users
we'll give Auditors the ability to see
the users
now that'll give us access to the pages
but it doesn't open up the nav menu so
let's go and adjust that too
so that's inside of shared nav menu
here
we have our home link our counter link
all right so open that one up to auditus
fetch data
same and use a list
same
okay so that should open up the front
end nicely let's see if it's changed
yeah Okay so we've got counter we can
click on that we can go to fetch data we
can access it okay but we can't get the
back end data because the API is still
locked down we haven't done the access
control checks on the back end and user
is the same so let's move it over to the
server now
so we'll start with the forecast
controller
so the weather forecast controller is
currently open to administrators and
operations so extend that one
and we'll give them access to the user's
controller
and we'll give them access to the roles
controller because they'll need to be
able to see the list of roles
they're probably getting a little bit
more access than what they need here and
that's one of the issues with role-based
Access Control it's not fine-grained
okay so we have to do a little bit more
work
but we won't do that today
so I've saved those changes it should be
ticking over okay let's see yeah we can
see the list of users
we can fetch some data if we click edit
we get access denied because I didn't
open up the edit page so we've probably
cleaned that up as well but I think
we've done enough work
so skipping back so we added the new
Auditors role to the existing access to
the existing application using basic
authorization techniques so role-based
Access Control you can see it was quite
a lot of work it wasn't simple to add at
all and we'll we'll have to do that
anytime we introduce a role we'll also
have to do that if authorization
requirements change
so with that in mind let's think about
what would flexible authorization look
like what would that mean well first it
would be easy to add new roles and to
configure access control for those roles
it would be easy to configure access
control for existing roles requirements
change permissions change we need to be
able to do that quickly
it would be good if we could remove
roles without impacting existing Access
Control checks obviously we have no hope
of doing that now because we have to go
and update the front end and the back
end and build test deploy publish right
there's so much to do it'd be great if
we can easily access uh
view the access control policies now
I've got us covered there I've got a uh
I've got a Wiki a little bit of a
markdown document that we can maintain
unfortunately it's already out of date
but as a developer I love documentation
so I'm going to get right back on that
uh it'd be really great if we could
support all of the all of the above as
standard application features okay I
don't want to have to maintain
documentation I don't want to have to
Code test and deploy these are simple
things
so now let's do another demonstration
let's do a demonstration where we
demonstrate what it would look like
adding a new role with the flexible
authorization approach
I'll close some of this down so it
doesn't get in our way
and we'll head over here so this is the
same application which has been upgraded
with flexible authorization capabilities
so I've extended ASP netcore
authorization to support for
missions-based Access Control
so we want to add the New Order to roll
I'm logged in as an administrator I'm
going to shoot over to roles that's a
new feature
you can see that I can edit and delete
roles and I'll add in auditors
I'll jump over to access control we
don't need to maintain a Wiki document
anymore we can see Access Control at any
point and we can configure it now we'd
like Auditors to have access to view the
users to count things and to check the
weather you can see administrators
automatically get access to everything
including new permissions that we Define
those changes are saved automatically so
I can go ahead and log out and log back
in as an as an auditor
all right so that's not working exactly
as I'd hoped
what have I done wrong I didn't assign
the role to the auditor all right let's
get back out I'm glad the passwords are
all the same
admin that's who that's who we want to
be that's great
users
auditor
Auditor's role there we go
logging out
back in
order to
there we go so they've got access to the
counter they've got access to fetch data
they can see the users we got rid of the
edit link we've got that little
fine-grained Access Control now so
that's a much better experience
so you've seen the basic approach you've
seen the flexible approach let's compare
a little bit
so the basic approach required us to
write code changes required us to test
we didn't do that but we'll get to that
build and deploy probably fix some bugs
you know that it's it's it's hard to get
role-based access control right
especially if there are a lot of
features
and documentation which we'll definitely
get to
flexible approach well as developers we
weren't really required what I just did
could have been completed by an
administrator or an authorized end user
so we were left with free time so that
means that we could have been working on
a new feature or a bug fix something a
little bit more exciting delivering
business value in other ways
so one more demonstration using flexible
authorization let's add a new permission
I'd like the orders to have the
capability to view that access control
grid but not to configure it so we'll
have to create a new permission for that
with this implementation I'm storing the
permission
in an enumeration and it's called
permissions so this is a bit Flags enum
and we'll go into that a little bit
view Access Control
will be the next permission that I
create
all right
now that that's in place I need to do
some authorization checks this time
instead of role-based authorization
checks we'll be doing permissions based
authorization checks so let's do the
front end first again
I want them to have access to access
control so we'll start with the nav menu
you can see here that we're using a
flexible authorized view component now
this is a component that I created to
extend the out of the box authorized
view component along with allowing me to
specify roles or policies I can also now
specify permissions
so you can see if you want to access
counter you need the counter permission
if you want to access fetch data you
need the forecast permission
let's have a find Access Control So
currently it's locked down to just those
that can configure Access Control
we'll change it over to configure or
View
so that should open up the nav menu
now we need to change the page so if we
go to the access control page which is
in admin
and open this up you can see the whole
page is locked down to configure so
we'll open it up to view as well
and scrolling down we have a little
check box here and this checkbox is
going to enable users to toggle that
permission now we only want to allow
users with configure Access Control to
actually be able to change access
control so we'll go ahead I've got some
code here which is going to use the
flexible authorized view component
instead of this just having a checkbox
so the flexible authorized view
component has specified an access
control check it requires configure
Access Control now if you're authorized
it will show a checkbox which will
enable editing if you're not authorized
that checkbox will be disabled and will
not allow editing
so that's fairly straightforward
let me think so now we need to go to the
server and apply some permissions based
Access Control there so if I head on
over to flexible auth server
controllers
and admin access control the whole
controller is locked down to configure
access control so we'll take that
we've got two actions one to get the
configuration and one to update so
configure access control is required to
update
and
view Access Control
actually both is required to get the
configuration so it's a either or
I think that should do it let's find out
I'll go ahead and restart just to be
sure
looks like uh we'll log in as admin
it'll probably refresh that actually
give it a sec
I'll go for it
plugging in I don't want to log in as
admin I actually I do that's lucky
it's gonna do it
it's gonna fail
just waiting
let me try again
oh there we go okay so we're logged in
as admin we can go to access control we
can see our new view Access Control
permission automatically assigned to
administrators we'll assign it to
Auditors as well
that's saved we'll log out
log back in
and change this over to auditor
we can see Access Control we can click
on it and we can see how it's configured
so now the Auditors have access to that
so that took a little bit of work right
but that's normal we built in a new
feature we implemented a new
authorization requirement so expect to
do some work when the authorization
requirements change
so now let's talk about this flexible
authorization engine the internal
workings of it and then we'll dive in
and have a look at the code and see how
it all fits together
so with this flexible authorization
approach we need to create the necessary
roles and permissions we're using
role-based and permissions-based access
control together
we need to assign permissions to roles
as required as defined by require
business requirements and we also need
to add an additional claim to the
authenticated user so we'll add the
permissions claim so now we'll have the
role claim and the permissions claim
we'll have permissions based access
control as required we've done that
using the authorize attribute using the
authorized View and there's also a
service in there the authorization
service which can do for missions-based
Access Control checks
and we will make this work
by using Dynamic authorization policies
so this is policy-based authorization so
we're combining three things to make
this work role-based permission based
which is new we're adding that in and
policy based
so we'll need to manage our roles we
probably all understand that roles
Define a logical group interview users
sometimes it might represent an
organizational Department such as
accounts or operations
administrators or any authenticated
sorry any authorized user really can
create a role as required
administrators will assign permissions
to roles and we now need to start
avoiding role-based authorization checks
okay if we're using the flexible
approach then any checks in code should
be permissions based they will only
change if the feature changes if we have
a new feature to introduce all the
authorization requirements around that
feature change
role-based tend to change because of
organizational changes restructures that
sort of thing
permissions we'll use those we need to
manage those they define granular access
to resources
developers create permissions as
necessary
but permissions are not assigned
directly to a user okay permissions are
assigned to a role and the user will
inherit the permissions of all assigned
roles so they can be assigned multiple
roles and they will get all of those
permissions
the authorization engine as mentioned
it's built entirely using policy-based
authorization so these are out of the
box features that we're using
we've got a custom authorized attribute
that we can specify the required
permissions
that set of required permissions is
actually translated into a policy name
and it's a special little name it might
say permissions 7 or permissions 101 and
that number is important that represents
the permissions required
and that policy will then be dynamically
created using a custom policy provider
and so
essentially the policy will be created
on the fly to enforce the permissions
that we've specified are required
so now we can have a look at the code
we'll start by revisiting our
permissions but I've got a little uh
interactive notebook that we can check
out to understand that a little bit
better
so as you saw before the permissions are
stored using c-sharp enums and I have a
simpler example here you can see that
they're stored using powers of two
and uh each little bit represents a flag
so you can see a is one whereas B is one
zero and we can combine these flags in
really interesting ways so we can
specify the user permissions as
permission a or C and that essentially
equals one plus one zero zero or
one zero one do you see how we've
brought those flags across combine them
together so five
distinctly represents a and C
and nothing else the required
permissions we've specified as a and b
or 11 those first two flags
now we can output those permissions as a
string so user permissions a comma C
Straight From the enumeration
required permissions A and B
we can output permissions as the integer
value
so you can see user permissions 5
required permissions three so a single
value to represent the permissions that
the user has
we can check permissions so looking at
the user's permissions they've got ANC
the required permissions A or B
are they authorized yes because they
have permission a
we can add permissions using logical or
operator so now the user has permissions
a b and c
we can remove permissions using the
logical exclusive or operator
so now the user's back to ANC
and
we can generate policy names based on
the permissions so the required
permissions are A and B which is
equivalent to three so the policy name
will be permissions three
and so pretty soon I'll show you how
asp.net core will take that policy name
and generate dynamically generate a
policy to enforce those permissions
we can update required permissions and a
policy name
you can see we've changed it a b and c
here's another value seven
and the policy name would be permission
seven
we can also get the value of the
permissions based on a policy name so
it's seven we extract that value we can
convert that back to the permissions
enumeration and we've got a B and C
again
so let's have a look at the code now
so we've seen
the permissions enumeration
we'll load it up again
that's it
we also have a permissions provider
which is just a helper method to give me
a friendly list of permissions so I can
display it on The View
but the real magic starts within the
flexible authorization policy provider
so this is extending the default
authorization policy provider with
asp.net core you can only have one
active policy provider and so it'll be
our flexible authorization one
now the way that this works
is we start in this method get policy
async given a policy name first thing we
do try to get the policy we don't want
to
generate a brand new policy if it's not
needed so we'll just try to get it
if the policy doesn't exist
and that particular policy
is one of our special ones you know it
starts with permissions and ends with a
number whoops
then we'll go ahead and create a policy
to match that
first thing we do is we extract the
permissions from the policy name
then we build a new authorization policy
we add One requirement that the user
must have these permissions
we build it and we add it and we return
it and of course if the policy already
exists we return it and if it's not one
of our policies that we want to generate
then what gets returned is null which is
the normal behavior for I believe for
this default authorization policy
provider
so this is building the policy let's
dive in and have a look at the
requirement the permission authorization
requirement
so you can see here this is implementing
eye authorization requirement from
asp.net core but it's just a container
for data it just contains the required
permissions so what is actually going to
do the check
it is
the permission authorization Handler
and this is where we retrieve the user
we retrieved the roles claim we build
the permissions claim uh sorry we Sorry
in this one actually we just retrieved
the permissions claim and then we check
against the user's permissions and the
required permissions so you can see here
we retrieve the claim if it doesn't
exist we bail and that means that the
user is not authorized as per this
requirement
if the permissions claim value is not
valid we bail
otherwise we cast it into a permissions
type we check to see if they have the
required permissions and if they do the
requirement succeeds and we return
if they don't then we bail again okay
nice
and simple we're just extending asp.net
core
let's have a look what else have we got
here
so this is the authorized attribute
we've been using that but we haven't
looked at the internal workings so this
particular one is just extending the
asp.net core authorization authorizer
tribute
and you can see
we're adding a new Constructor so we can
pass in the permissions nice to have
and we have this permissions property
what we're doing here we're not storing
the permissions
we're generating the policy name and
storing that so even at this level with
our custom authorized attribute we're
just using policy-based authorization
what else do we have
we've got our custom claim type but
that's just for the claim name
we've got the eye authorization service
extensions which is great so when you're
doing authorization checks with asp.net
core sometimes it's nice to use the eye
authorization server so if you have some
procedural checks some code that where
you want to do certain authorization
checks you can use this service so I've
gone ahead and built an extension on it
so you can go ahead and do
permissions-based authorization checks
should cover all of the bases
let's see if we've looked at the Handler
we've looked at the requirement we've
looked at permissions we didn't look at
the policy name helper this one's very
straightforward it's responsible for
generating a policy name
given a set of permissions it's
responsible for getting the permissions
from a policy name and also checking to
see if it is a valid policy name I think
I need a better method name for that I
think I need to say is this a
permissions policy name or is this a
permissions policy something a little
bit more descriptive but that's the
point of it so check if it's one of our
policies that we'd like to dynamically
generate
all right
I think that is it
okay
so today we looked at authorization with
asp.net core I demonstrated a basic
approach to authorization using
role-based access control now this is a
very typical approach so I'm sure a lot
of us here have used it
with this approach we saw that a simple
requirement such as adding an auditor
role took a lot of effort we had to
write code we had to test that code
build deploy document probably fix some
bugs we then looked at the flexible
authorization approach now the flexible
authorization approach was a dream if we
needed to add a new role or a permission
we combined role-based authorization
with permissions based authorization
which we introduced and we used
policy-based authorization to
dynamically generate policies to enforce
those permissions
now if you have a simple application
with a small user base the flexible
approach to authorization is probably
Overkill
you could get by with the basic approach
but for most large production
applications especially in in big
Enterprises the flexible approach to
authorization is essential
with the flexible approach you'll be
able to isolate your code base from
organizational changes
it'll free up developers to focus on
delivering business value such as fixing
bugs or delivering new features
and it will put the power of Access
Control into the hands of Administrators
and other authorized users
thanks for attending my talk I hope
you've enjoyed it if you'd like to learn
more you can check out the code and
slides on GitHub you'll find it at
github.com forward slash Jason Taylor
Dev forward slash flexible Dash asp.net
core Dash authorization